the white house convened a meeting this
was a few days ago with
top tick-tock influencers
giving them a briefing
on the ukraine situation this also is
not a joke they actually did this one of
the influencers was a girl named ellie
zeiler
who is famous for making eight-second
videos where she she dances and this is
of course on tick-tock this is there are
a lot of people become
famous on tik-tok
for just dancing and not even full
performances but just eight or nine
seconds
and um anyway just as an example here's
one of the the videos of ellie's i was
good she's got like 10 million fans okay
it's a massively famous person
and here she is let's watch
okay so that
that's 10 million
10 million fans for that
now i'm no one to judge but but the
dancing isn't even
if you're to look people have been
ever since the the invention of modern
media there have been people becoming
massively massively famous because
they're good dancers
and i'll admit that i that there's a
certain bias for me because i don't
really understand that at all i don't
understand why anyone should get famous
and wealthy because they can dance i
mean who really cares that much
um but at least you know
30 years ago
you're you're famous for dancing and
it's like you because you're like
actually a really good dancer now that's
not even good dancing right that's
that's
am i wrong again i'm not a good judge of
this but that is very lackluster dancing
that is just barely a step above a
bridesmaid at a wedding in terms of
dancing skills maybe not even that good
and that gives you 10 million followers
that's it that's all you got to do just
do a couple of moves five five six
seconds 10 million followers and you're
getting invited to the white house
for a debriefing on foreign policy while
war rages in europe and so they got the
debriefing and now all the tick tock
influencers it just so happens what do
you know they met with joe biden and now
they're all making videos
and for many of them this is the maybe
the first time they've actually spoken
in a video because usually they're just
dancing
and now they're all making videos
explaining how all the bad stuff in the
world happening right now it's all
putin's fault it's definitely not
biden's fault so here's uh zeiler
filling in filling her fans in on this
crucial fact why is gas so expensive and
why is the united states inflation rate
at a four-time decade high
i had the opportunity to ask the white
house why gas down the street is seven
dollars and here's what they said
the obvious reason we are getting out of
a two-year pandemic when use goes up
price goes up but the call is
predominantly about ukraine and russia
so how does that relate russia is one of
the top three producers of oil and it is
actually their number one revenue source
now with putin starting this horrific
fight between ukraine and russia nobody
wants to work with him and do an
international trade so with people being
scared of war and limited resources
prices are bound to go up as well for
the people who can't pay seven dollars
for a gallon of gas there's an app
called gas buddy that shows you the
cheapest gas near you as well as a link
in my buyout to donate to the misplaced
refugees of ukraine
so first video she's made that was more
than eight seconds long i mean that for
her what that because that's like 45
seconds
that is she might as well be reciting
war and peace this is this is her
magnum opus is a 45 second video and
she's she's actually speaking
and uh and she wants to let us all know
that this is all this is all uh putin's
fault it's not me because it's not
biden's fault
gas prices and everything
even though gas prices were trending up
already
before all of this it's still all
putin's fault
we can't blame joe biden but remember
something else
all of these
other countries
countries that are autocratic
dictatorial
where where you get a lot of propaganda
government propaganda
media that that parades around as as if
it's free and independent but really
it's getting all of its talking points
and marching orders from the media and
from the government rather um you know
we don't have that here we're we're much
better than that here we don't we don't
we don't do that right
no of course we do
and there's just there's just something
even creepier about it
when they're bringing we're used to this
from cable news we're used to the
government propaganda from cable news
and most of the people
watching cable news you you basically
know that that's what you're gonna get
okay so the people watching there are
only seven people watching cnn
um they're all 65 and older and they're
there because they want the left-wing
propaganda msnbc it's three it's
actually three people but they're from
the same group of cnn a few drop off and
we'll watch msnbc again but they're
there
because they want the propaganda
um
[Music]
and the buy administration knows that
well okay we've got we've got pretty
much the entire media except for fox
that will that's at our beck and caller
they'll do whatever we want
um
you know we blow whistle they'll come
running along like dogs and do what we
want to do and that's that's great for
them
but it only goes so far because of the
people that you're accessing
now you want to get to younger people
you want to get the kids
people that aren't really prepared don't
understand what they're being told
uh they're just there for the dancing
videos they're not really there and
prepared for the propaganda makes them
more susceptible to it actually
that's what the by administration is
doing
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated